ALL RIGHT, SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
7:08 HERE ON THE EAST COAST.
LET’S BRING IN SENATOR TOM
COTTON REPUBLICAN FROM ARKANSAS.
A MEMBER OF THE SENATE ARMED
SERVICES COMMITTEE AND SENATE
SELECT INTEL COMMITTEE, AND HE
HAS BEEN ISOLATING JUST LIKE THE
REST OF US.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, SENATOR.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT.
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF A DELAY
HERE.
ALL RIGHT.
LET’S START WITH WHAT YOU MAKE
OF THE PRESIDENT’S PLAN TO
REOPEN THE COUNTRY?
>> THE PRESIDENT’S PLAN IS
MEASURED.
IT’S JUDICIOUS.
IT’S THE RIGHT APPROACH.
WE CAN’T SET AN ARBITRARY
DEADLINE.
WE CAN’T HAVE A SINGLE PLAN FOR
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
OBVIOUSLY SOME PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY HIT HARD LIKE NEW YORK
OR DETROIT.
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY,
ESPECIALLY THE RURAL PARTS HAVE
SEEN VERY LITTLE CASES AT ALL.
AS LONG AS THAT REMAINS THE
CASE, I THINK IT’S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO TO ENCOURAGE OUR
GOVERNORS TO BEGIN ON A SLOW,
GRADUAL CALIBRATED BASIS TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
TO GET PEOPLE BACK TO THEIR
NORMAL ROUTINES.
TAKING APPROPRIATE MEASURES LIKE
MAINTAINING DISTANCES AT THE
WORKPLACE OR IN SHOPS, WEARING
MASKS AND SO FORTH.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE TO BE PREPARED
FOR ANY SURGE IN NEW CASES AS WE
BEGIN TO DO THAT.
BUT I THINK IT’S THE RIGHT
APPROACH TO BEGIN TO GET THE
ECONOMY BACK ON ITS FEET.
AINSLEY: LET’S TALK ABOUT THE
LETTER THAT REPUBLICANS SENT TO
THE PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT
FUNDING FOR THE W.H.O.
I KNOW THAT NOW DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING THAT HE IS VIOLATING THE
SAME SPENDING LAWS THAT BROUGHT
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT AGAIN.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT ALLOWED TO
DO THIS AND TAKE AWAY FUNDING
FROM THE W.H.O.
IN THE LETTER THAT THE
REPUBLICANS SENT, IT SAID
BASICALLY WE NEED TO JUST GET
THE LEADER OUT OF THE W.H.O. AND
THEN WE WILL CONTINUE FUNDING.
HERE IS AN EXSERENITY FROM EXCER
LETTER THAT WAS SENT:
HAVE YOU HEARD ANYTHING FROM THE
PRESIDENT ON THAT?
IS HE GOING TO RECOMMEND THE
FIRING OF HIM?
>> WELL, I THINK THE ONLY WAY WE
CAN HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE
W.H.O. IN THE SHORT-TERM IS IF
DR. TEDROS AND SENIOR TEAM
LEAVES.
HE WAS A WELL-ESTABLISH
REPUTATION FOR CORRUPTION GOING
BACK TO MINISTER IN ETHIOPIA
WHEN CHINA WAS HANDING ’OW OUT
BRIBES BELTON ROAD INITIATIVE.
AND GOING BACK TO THE EARLIEST
DAYS OF THIS PANDEMIC THE W.H.O.
UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP SEEMED TO
PRIORITIZE POLITICAL CORRECTNESS
AND SUCKING UP TO CHINA NOT
TRYING TO FOCUS ON WHAT THEIR
NAME CALLS FOR WHICH IS WORLD
HEALTH.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
THERE HAS BEEN A PROBLEM.
WE ALLOWED CHINA TO GET
DOMINANCE IN THERE DATING BACK
TWO ADMINISTRATIONS.
WE’LL FIND OURSELVES CAUGHT.
MEANWHILE, LET’S TALK ABOUT
CHINA.
WE WATCHED JAPAN MAKE A NATIONAL
MOVEMENT TO PULL MANUFACTURING
OUT.
WE HAVE SEEN STATEMENTS FROM THE
U.K. AND FRANCE SHOWING HOW
UPSET THEY ARE WITH THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY WITH THIS WHOLE
PANDEMIC THAT HAS POISONED 180
COUNTRIES.
SO, RIGHT NOW, WITH THEIR
ECONOMY SHRUNK AT 7%, WHAT,
SENATOR TOM COTTON, DO YOU THINK
SHOULD BE THE NEXT STEP AS MORE
AND MORE FOCUS IS ON THAT LAB IN
WUHAN THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT IN
JANUARY WHERE YOU THOUGHT THIS
THING COULD HAVE EMANATED FROM?
>>
>> YEAH.
BRIAN, THE CIRCUMSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE, WHICH I BEGAN TO SITE
IN JANUARY IS STACKING UP PRETTY
QUICKLY THAT THIS VIRUS MAY HAVE
ORIGINATED IN THOSE LABS IN
WUHAN.
WE KNEW FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
THAT THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY’S FRONT STORY ABOUT THE
FOOD MARKET WAS PROBABLY WRONG.
FOR ONE, IT APPEARS THAT THEY
DON’T EVEN SELL THE KIND OF BATS
AT THAT MARKET FROM WHICH THIS
VIRUS ORIGINATED.
AND, TWO, CHINESE SCIENTISTS IN
AN AUTHORITATIVE STUDY AS EARLY
AS JANUARY FOUND ABOUT A THIRD
THE EARLY CASES HAD NO CONTACT
WITH THE FOOD MARKET WHATSOEVER.
WE KNOW THAT CHINA HAS A VERY
SLOPPY HISTORY OF LABORATORY
SAFETY.
SOME OF OUR OWN DIPLOMATS AT THE
EMBASSY IN CHINA WENT TO THESE
LABS AS FAR AS BACK AS TWO YEARS
AGO AND SAID THE PRACTICES THERE
WERE VERY ALARMING.
AND YOU CAN SEE HOW CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY HAS CONTINUED TO
LIE ABOUT THIS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING AS IF THEY HAVE
SOMETHING TO COVER UP.
IF THAT’S THE CASE, IT REALLY IS
THE BIGGEST, COSTLIEST MOST
DEADLIEST COVER-UP IN THE
HISTORY OF MANKIND.
STEVE: NO KIDDING.
SENATOR, LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WOUND UP WITH
$1,200 DIRECTLY DEPOSITED IN
THEIR ACCOUNTS OVER THE LAST
WEEK OR SO.
BUT, BECAUSE THERE HAS BEEN SUCH
CONFLICTING SIGNALS FROM
WASHINGTON ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE
SBA HAS -- SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION HAS RUN OUT OF
MONEY RIGHT NOW FOR THESE LOANS
AND PEOPLE DON’T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THE NEXT STEP IS UNTIL THE
SENATE DOES SOMETHING AND
CONGRESS DOES SOMETHING.
BUT, REGARDING JUST THOSE CHECKS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN, ODDLY,
IT SEEMS LIKES THERE IS LOT OF
MISINFORMATION.
I HAD TWO PEOPLE ASK ME, THEY
SAID OKAY, THAT 1200 BUCKS, I
HAVE GOT TO PAY IT BACK NEXT
YEAR, RIGHT?
AND I SAID NO.
YOU GET TO KEEP THAT THIS IS NOT
A LOAN OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
IT’S TO STIMULATE THE ECONOMY.
AND TO GET TO YOU BUY GROCERIES
AND EVERYTHING LIKE THAT, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
FOR ANYONE MAKING LESS THAN
$75,000 OR ANY FAMILY MAKING
LESS THAN $150,000, IT’S $1,200
A PERSON, $500 PER CHILD.
THOSE ARE SIMPLY PAYMENTS
DESIGNED TO HELP OUR PEOPLE GET
THROUGH THE WORST OF THIS
CRISIS.
IT DOESN’T HAVE TO BE PAID BACK
IN THE FUTURE.
IT’S DESIGNED TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU COULD PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
AT THE END OF THE WEEK, THAT YOU
CAN PAY THE BILLS AND PUT A ROOF
OVER YOUR KID’S HEAD AT THE END
OF THE MONTH AS WE GET THROUGH
THE WORSE OF THIS CRISIS,
HOPEFULLY SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER.
THOSE CHECKS ARE DESIGNED AS
EMERGENCY LIFELINE FOR OUR
FAMILIES.
AINSLEY: SENATOR, OUR ANCHOR AND
FRIEND BRET BAIER WHO LIVES IN
D.C. IS TALKING TO THESE
LAWMAKERS ON BOTH SIDES LEFT AND
RIGHT, HE SAID THAT THEY ARE
DISCUSSING A POSSIBLE PAYBACK
FOR CHINA AND ONE PAT COULD BE
SUING CHINA.
CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT FOR THEIR
NEGLIGENCE IN THIS.
IS THAT POSSIBLE?
>> YEAH, AINSLEY, WITH
LEGISLATION I HAVE INTRODUCED
WITH DAN CRENSHAW IT WILL BE
POSSIBLE.
FOREIGN SOVEREIGN IMMUNITIES ACT
ALLOWS FOREIGN OFFICIALS TO BE
SUED IN OUR COURTS.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT CONGRESS
DID FOR THE VICTIMS OF 9/11.
WE SHOULD DO IT FOR THE VICTIMS
OF THIS PANDEMIC.
THAT’S JUST ONE STEP WE CAN TAKE
THERE IS A LOT OF OTHER THINGS
WE CAN DO AS WELL.
FOR INSTANCE REVOKING CHINESE
VISAS FOR THE KIDS OF CHINESE
OLE GUY DARKS STUDYING IN
ADVANCED SCIENTIFIC COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND OTHER KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGICAL FIELDS THEY GO
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES OR
SIMPLY BRINGING BACK MORE OF OUR
MANUFACTURING CAPACITY SO WE
CREATE JOBS HERE.
JOBS THAT ARE GOING TO HELP
ENSURE OUR SAFETY AND OUR HEALTH
IN THE FUTURE.
BRIAN: SENATOR, I’M GOING TO PUT
YOU IN A DIFFICULT POSITION.
I WILL PUT YOU IN THE WHITE
HOUSE FOR A SECOND.
THE PRESIDENT IS IN A TOUGH
SPOT.
IS HE CLOSE TO DOING A DEAL WITH
THE OTHER ECONOMIC BEHEMOTH AND
THAT’S CHINA AT THE SAME TIME HE
KNOWS THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE.
AT THE SAME TIME HE KNOWS
CURRENTLY WE HAVE A LOT OF OUR
MANUFACTURING THERE AND A LOT OF
OUR PPE WE NEED TO COME OUT OF
THERE.
HOW DO YOU DO THIS GRADUALLY IN
A WAY THAT’S DIPLOMATICALLY
SAVVY AND NOT EMOTIONAL AT A
TIME LIKE THIS WHERE CURRENTLY
WE ARE INTERLOCKED?
>> YEAH, BRIAN, SADLY, WE ARE IN
A SITUATION WHERE CHINA DOES
HAVE THE MARKET CORNERED ON
THINGS LIKE MASKS AND GLOVES AND
OTHER MEDICAL SPLICE.
EVEN ON SOME OF THE COMPONENTS
FOR TESTING.
AND JUST THIS WEEK IT WAS
REPORTED THAT CHINA IS
WITHHOLDING A LOT OF THAT
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT FROM THE
UNITED STATES ON SPURIOUS
GROUNDS.
SO OBVIOUSLY WE DON’T WANT TO
RUSH INTO THIS CHANGE.
WE DON’T WANT TO SAY THAT WE ARE
GOING TO PUT IMPORT BANS ON
CHINESE GOODS IN PLACE NEXT WEEK
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE THOSE
GOODS NOW TO PROTECT OUR DOCTORS
AND OUR NURSES AND ALL THE
PEOPLE STRUGGLING WITH THIS
VIRUS.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO BEGIN TO
PLAN FOR HOW WE ARE NOT GOING TO
BE DEPENDENT ON CHINA IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE THIS CANNOT BE
ALLOWED TO EVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
BRIAN: WE HAVE MAKE OUR OWN